- [Mark] All right, David?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] David, where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- Massachusetts.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood,
you had both of your
parents when you were a kid?
- [David] Yeah.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- [David] Not that happy.
- [Mark] What kind of stuff went on?
- It's my fault, oh, I had,
well, you know, problems.
- [Mark] What do you, I
mean, what do you mean?
- Oh.
(coughs)
It's, I always felt like I didn't belong
in certain groups.
Always a misfit.
- [Mark] Always a misfit.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And what, tell me
about your parents, they were?
- Oh Jesus, nice people, very nice people.
I didn't treat them nice but.
- [Mark] Were you adopted or-?
- I'm adopted.
- [Mark] You're adopted?
- Yes.
- [Mark] And, but no
traumatic events, nothing.
It's more that you're,
you're the troublemaker?
- Sort of.
Some things were my
fault, maybe most of it,
but I had my problems.
- [Mark] Yeah, and what,
do you know anything
about your blood, your parents?
- None whatsoever.
- [Mark] Nothing.
And so what kind of kid
were you in high school?
- What?
- [Mark] What kind of kid
were you in high school?
- Misfit.
- [Mark] And so you went
on your own at what age?
- Huh?
- [Mark] You went out
on your own at what age?
- Yeah, when I was 17, 16, 17.
- [Mark] Did you finish-
- I got my GED.
- [Mark] You did, okay.
And where'd you go from there?
- Oh, crappy job, one
crappy job to another.
- [Mark] What kind of jobs you did?
- Dish washing, I worked, um (coughs)
I don't know if I can remember, (coughs)
but I worked at Hayes
and Bickford's in Boston,
they had these cafeterias.
They're not around anymore,
them and Waldorf. (coughs)
You remember Foxy's here in San Francisco?
- [Mark] Don't.
- They had a whole group of them.
They were owned by the
way by the same people.
It's kind of, (coughs) I
guess they went out of style.
You know, these cafeterias.
- [Mark] Right.
- I know they don't have
them any around anymore.
- [Mark] So do you have a family?
Do you have kids of your own?
- No, not that, no.
- [Mark] Ever married?
- No.
- [Mark] Ever been in love?
- Maybe.
- [Mark] So you, have you
done prison time for anything?
- No.
- [Mark] Stayed out of
jail and prison stayed-?
- I've been to jail, yes.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Are drugs a part of your life?
- What?
- [Mark] Are drugs a part of your life?
- No, (laughs) no.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You're living here in the Tenderloin.
- Yes.
- [Mark] In San Francisco,
you've been here since when?
- 1981.
- [Mark] It's a long time.
- Yes.
- [Mark] And you're staying
in one of the hotels now?
- No, it's an apartment, it's
not a very nice apartment,
but it's an apartment.
- [Mark] And what do you do how
do you support yourself now?
- I'm on (indistinct).
- [Mark] So you're getting
money from the government?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And were you ever homeless?
- Maybe at the longest
maybe a month at a time.
- [Mark] Okay.
- And not very many times.
- [Mark] So this, this misfit
outcast image that you have
of yourself, do you think that came from,
from anything that
happened in your childhood
or was it maybe your blood parents or?
- Maybe something I maybe
it's in my ancestry.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Mark] The fact that
you were adopted kind of-
- Yeah, but I don't think that's it.
- [Mark] Yeah.
What's the most important lesson
you've learned in your life?
- (coughs) Oh, there's
a lot of them I guess.
I've learned to keep my mouth shut.
(Mark laughing)
You can learn a lot.
- [Mark] That's a good one.
- I used to be, you know, kind of bud
in people's conversations.
Number one, they don't like it.
Number two, you kind of keep
quiet, you can learn something.
That's very true I think. (coughs)
- [Mark] Yeah, do you have friends?
- Um, I have friends, yeah.
Mainly from the soup kitchens I work in.
- [Mark] Did you feel
like you were ever loved
as a child or?
- Not really, you know.
Love is a strong emotion, but no.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Is there anyone that you trust?
- Oh, several people I trust, yeah.
- [Mark] Yeah, that's
important to have, too.
And are you happy?
- Not really.
- [Mark] No?
- So-so, you know.
I don't think, I don't
think most people are happy.
- [Mark] No, I agree with that. (laughs)
That's kinda what my channel's about.
What, what do you think
gets in the way of that
more than anything, for
yourself or for other people?
- Just life itself I guess.
Trying to get along with other people.
- [Mark] Yeah.
Do you wish you would had
done anything different
about your life?
- [David] Oh, yeah.
- [Mark] Any regrets?
- [David] I wish I'd
gotten, got a job, I know,
lead a more regular life, you know.
Maybe have a girlfriend, but
none that, that didn't work.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- [David] Well, I mean,
in the early, in the 70s.
- [Mark] What were you doing back then?
- [David] (coughs) I
was on welfare, but um,
I don't know, things worked for you.
You met people.
I had that three or four girls,
it didn't amount to
anything, but you know.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- [David] 74.
- [Mark] 74.
Do you see the world as a good place
or do you see it as dangerous and
if you know, how do you see the world?
- [David] I think it's getting worse.
(coughs)
- [Mark] But people in
general, you see them as
do you see people as good?
- [David] I mean, you
look, I think we're growing
back into fascism.
Just look at the hitting
in Philippines, Brazil,
they even knocked Poland,
did you keep up with Poland?
- [Mark] I don't.
- (coughs) They had an election,
it was some guy that was kind of a fascist
but he lost out in the election.
I think that was good news.
Probably Russia, what else?
All these countries, Hungary, (coughs)
Philippines, Brazil, done with it.
Do you ever keep up with
the news in these places?
- [Mark] I don't.
- Huh?
- Oh, there's some more,
(coughs) Putin is a fascist.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- Definitely.
- [Mark] And who you be
voting for this fall?
- Oh, Biden, who are you probably?
- [Mark] Yeah, I'm
probably not gonna vote,
I'll just stay out of it.
- Hm, well.
- [Mark] Cause I'm in California,
so guess who's gonna win?
- I think I unfortunately,
there's a good chance Trump will.
- [Mark] Really?
- Yeah.
- [David] And not California, but-
- Not California, but
the rest of the country.
- [Mark] I'll be too busy editing
to get off of my ass and vote.
But, but you're happy here in California.
Do you think just in general?
- It's probably the only
place I can live in.
- [Mike] You, you won't be
going back to Massachusetts?
- No, no, no, no.
Besides my sisters, she's adopted,
but they live in the Maryland, anyway.
I'm keeping track, but-
- [Mark] That's nice.
- But they live in Maryland, so.
I don't think anybody I
know lives in Massachusetts.
- [Mark] You ever, did you ever wanna get
in touch with your actual parents?
- [David] Um, I used to, I've
kinda given up, given that up.
- [Mike] Yeah.
- [David] They'd be dead by now.
- [Mark] They're probably
not around now, yeah.
All right, David, well,
thank you so much for talking
with me and good luck with
whatever you do from here.
- Alright.
- [Mark] Thank you, man.